podría smell former NFL wide receiver
won a Super Bowl as well
Syracuse legend he works for the Ravens
pre and post game coverage and Qadri
joins us now
Kadri good morning how are you dan
what's going on with you now true or
false
did you help Todd Fritz's son get into
Syracuse I pulled some strings for him
okay I kind of made a couple calls yeah
that's what we thought that's right
thanks for being honest listen we won
them all we're going to go ahead bring a
man it's going to enhance the school's
credibility boom we had him in there all
right
yeah I told Todd he can't just start
booking Syracuse alum you know Rob
Conrad he wanted to have on today Dwight
Freeney today and Jerry McNamara and I
said no probably you know just one
Syracuse alum do your Ravens have any
issues like as you take this team goes
into the postseason what is the biggest
concern you have for the Ravens so I
think if you look at the last few weeks
kind of shockingly I would say special
teams and here's why you know what the
playoffs field position matters big
plays matter you know momentum capturing
it keeping it it definitely is something
that you know you you covet when you you
get into the postseason for the Ravens I
think with Justin Tucker for example you
know missing an extra point and you know
everyone in M&T Bank Stadium you know
we're holding our collective breath
because that's just unheard of you know
you talk about the most accurate kicker
and no league history you look at you
know Sam Cooke thicknes punt block and
you just look at you know just how
incredible he's been and the way he's
been able to just place the ball when he
punched it to wherever you know he's a
ton of seals and so you know little
mistakes like that I think you know can
can hurt a team and so no I think that's
first and foremost but then also there
have been little you know kind of chinks
in the armor defensively
be the 49ers getting to the outside and
really getting big chunk plays in the
running game we saw that back in week
four with Nick Jobs and the way he was
able to run it so effectively against
the Ravens obviously for passing a tax
standpoint that's something where I
think back times have been break down to
communication and a more seasoned
playoffs
quarterback can take advantage of some
of the mistakes so well would you know
there are some kinks there there's
nothing that's necessarily person give
me the team that you don't want to face
in the postseason I think Tennessee they
match up pretty pretty well against
everyone I know New England just because
of their experience and you know Bill
Belichick you know that little
mastermind of his trying to figure out
you know the way in which Greg Roman and
Lamar kind of operate I think you know
they would be the one that would kind of
be the thorn in the side I would
probably say them everybody else I think
they match up really well against I
think NFC so if it became a game where
yeah you know what his Super Bowl look
like I would not want to face a 49ers
team I think the 49ers their speed on
their defense but at the same time the
way in which their offense operates it's
incredibly difficult to defend and I
think they would be the one that I
wouldn't want to see the Ravens face if
I would have told you in August Lamar
Jackson is going to be the MVP
what would you say yeah let's put some
money on it and I'll tie it with us
not necessarily bet against him just for
the sake of it but from what I saw you
know as the season wound down in 2018
the offseason you just don't know and
I've said this before
rookies when you get into the league you
have your strengths and it takes a guy
to figure out how to work on his
weaknesses
often times it might be their second or
third year may be their fourth year
before they finally get it and make
their weaknesses their strength can be a
complete player the position a
quarterback I mean we've seen that you
know throughout where guys it takes them
forever to kind of become an upper tier
quarterback and so for Lamar who was
having difficulty you know throwing the
football too you know the way he came
into camp
you know tight spirals you know the way
he was having a command of the offense
and the way he grew you know right from
the jump going down to Miami and just
carrying it through the season
it's remarkable my hat's off to all for
his hard work and his dedication to
improve in his craft
who knew that Mark Ingram was the
stand-up comedian the host of this team
feels like he's been the biggest
proponent advocate cheerleader for lamar
jackson if you need a hype man go ahead
and get him Mark Ingram I mean last year
you know when you know that's obviously
the season is over and the offseason
everybody's like oh my god you know
who's gonna fill in the the leadership
void and know guys this team is going to
look you know different and you know
because for years you've had those
big-name guys you've had that terrell
suggs and you know clearly ray and then
you know you had some big-name players
these four senior on off the side
whatever but I think for this team and
the way they just it's like marks has
been here his entire career that's new
that's what we've seen with with him and
just how he's been in his leadership
role and just it is his height their
role with with Lamar I think it's
perfect
did you ever race your brother Dan so
let's just say on your show for once and
for all
if there was ever a question that has
been asked by me from every [ __ ] Notre
Dame alumni to the history of man oh my
god I'll sure your brother apply coffee
so fast who's faster
and you don't understand 0 to 10 yards I
kid you not Tim Brown was talking to me
- one time we were down about hanging
out it was him
my brother James Jett Alexander right
and will it go who arguably they can all
run 4.3 seconds in the 40-yard dash in
their sleep Tim was like I don't think
people understand just how fast your
brother is we would all be doing sprints
and literally the first is 0 to 10 your
brother is 3 yards ahead of us my
brother has a otherworldly first step
speed that you just said teach the DNA
was passed on to him and when my father
my mom were like together it forgot to
give it to me all right okay okay but
rocket Ismail who was runner up
Notre Dame for the Heisman and one of
the fastest players who's ever played
this sport they somebody said that he
was clocked under four to one nine was
it official and your best was four three
two I was slow I mean it's fast but
that's slow that's fast but it's slow it
will get you by people but it won't like
just put this guy in the back like four
three four three is one of the fastest
times in the NFL when you were playing
but you're not even close to being the
fastest guy in your own family at the
time correct yeah it was like he would
run my brother I've learned the art of
being content there's low there is you
know give them a burst of slow I would
do I'll give them a burst of slow I'm
content with being just average fast for
three is average fast in your in your
household what do you think what do you
think rocket would run the 40 now so we
actually were up in New York he was
inducted in the castleball Hall of Fame
and you know we're sitting there and I'm
watching his highlight tape and I think
glory hole was up there Tory Holtz was
was no great as far as just highlight at
North Pond State and then my brothers
got up on the house like oh unreal just
blazing and I think I could take him now
though I think I can't he had some ice
cream up on the dais the belly was
looking a little bit different I think I
could take them it took it took a long
time but you finally got him where you
where you want him where you can finally
beat your brother in a 40-yard dash 49
years dad Godrej great to hear from you
and have fun with the Ravens maybe we'll
see it the Super Bowl and give our best
to your brother as well absolutely
prevalent as always that's the cadre I
smell a former NFL wide receiver for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]